the Shawnee last time we spoke to you is
for your neck so for people who've seen
that how would you compare your
character in Patrick and the film itself
well it's so different which is great
because we kind of fall under the same
you know horror category but these films
are so so very different from one
another I felt like with your next I
really got to step into that dream
action role that that I'd been craving
and and show that more kind of kick ass
girl fights back person that I that I
wanted to portray and with this one it
was more of a challenging in the fact
that my main co-star was in a coma for
the movie so it taught me a lot about
reacting and was definitely more on the
on the drama side of a vaccine which is
where I came from so you know it was a
nice to get back in touch with just not
the heavier drama of the horror scene
and child's dance and rachel Griffiths
were kind of my inspiration for that it
was really really good now your lead
co-star may be in a coma but he has
certain powers didn't he tell us about
that yeah yeah the Jackson Gallagher
plays Patrick and we are knew Patrick is
younger better-looking you know just
just to create more of a I guess a
reality sense of one my character would
be so drawn to him and there's just I
think the adaptations that were sort of
formed right here and this one have just
been very cool for a remake the original
subject was telekinesis so we've kind of
had all these advances in technology
since and gives us the opportunity to
really push the script forward but to be
acting with with Jackson was was a blast
because he he had to just like very
still and and not blink and it's
actually not it's not it's not that easy
to do that but he would shock me and
open his eyes and wake up and and scare
the crap out of me a lot so he kept me
on my toes it was kept a very sort of
dark and gothic chiller of a storyline
uplifting and fun and you mentioned
being scared there by Jackson suddenly
we're you know what scares you in real
life
Oh in real life for this one we worked
very heavily again as we did in your
next with the prosthetic Department and
you know putting wounds on people and
that you know working with with even
though it's fake but working with fake
blood and and seeing how amazing the
prosthetics Department actually are at
creating these injuries you forget
sometimes that people aren't actually
injured and you're walking around set
and thinking oh you okay you go to ask
you okay and so no I'm just good it's
just a you know obviously makeup but
that always freaks me out just watching
everybody sort of walking around set
just looking like me half-dead but it
was good it was good I think the other
thing that was really good it didn't so
much freak me out on this one but it
really gave me my first sense of like
that real action woman kind of role I
was hooked up to so many rigs in this in
this film I did all my own stunts for
the movie which is a big kind of
recommendation of mine that I can't that
I want to do my own stunts and I was
hooked up in this one to two rigs and
you know was sent flying backwards like
20 feet into crash pads that were
against walls and I always loved working
really heavily with with the stunt
Department and they're just a hoot to
work with and I'm kind of the fearless
sort of follower I guess you'd say I
follower fearlessly stupidly but I will
do anything they do so I had a blast
getting thrown around on this one and
speaking of getting thrown around we
know you've got a female Expendables
that coming up how much you looking
forward to them what do you think about
the idea of an all-female Expendables
movie I think it's a great idea
I really do because if they're gonna do
one with the guys and it works then I
think they're gonna they're gonna get
away with doing one with the girls and
it's gonna work just as well if not
better because it's almost less
predictable you know it's kind of
we know we expect these guys to be to be
big and tough and and go out and sort of
save the day but when a woman does it
there's something kind of really cool
about it especially when you believe it
and I think that the cast that we're
putting together right now are so
genuine action women that that it's
gonna we're all very different as well
so it's gonna it's gonna be very very
cool very interesting I'm really looking
forward to I mean we've got Gina Carano
and Katee Sackhoff abroad already
there's rumors of Linda Hamilton and Pam
Grier what can you tell us about that
yeah I could tell you that that I I'm as
clued in as you are so you know it's all
gonna be very exciting when I think the
final cast is announced what can we look
forward to you think in terms of the
female movie oh I mean I just think it
feel like the reason from what I'm aware
anyway that you're next worked for me
was that so many females came up to me
after the film and and and and just
loved watching a woman kick butt and
it's just it's it's really quite rare
you know that that we find a woman is
able to step into these roles and and
and sort of have an impact and an effect
on other women out there and my main
main thing that I took out of your necks
was encouraging women to get into
self-defense and you know really feel
like they're capable of protecting
themselves if they had to and I just
think that's really important so if
there was one thing that we could take
out of maybe a female Expendables I
would encourage the same message you
know to get out there and make that big
just be kind of as confident as you can
in that if something happened we could
you know at least know that we have the
skill to do what could be necessary
now we're hearings have the title things
like Expendables be e double L EA what
do you think of that that's cute I you
know the title
you know is not for me to decide I just
whatever the title is if I'm in the film
I'll be very very grateful we can't wait
to see you in it when do you think you
might be stopped filming what stage
you're at at the moment
well I'm aware we're shooting next year
I couldn't tell you exactly when in the
year but we're looking for a 2015
release yeah and you bet you're looking
forward to getting your teeth into some
more stunt thing though that's what I'm
saying I see yeah I don't want to see a
shiny Vincent stunt double on that cold
sheet the day I say that is the day I go
hang on a minute what's going on here I
didn't sign up for this
no I love doing my own stunts and I love
action movies and I love high drama so
if I can put them all together and and
do everything as much like a myself then
that is that's that's why I'm in this
business and that's that's my dream so
we'll say the last time you met Shani we
talked about female action roles like
Lara Croft we talked about female
superhero roles like a lecturer now I'm
wondering if JJ Abrams bring you at for
example and said how about one of the
Star Wars maybe he's coming up is that
the kind of thing you'd be into as well
and what who do you like to be oh you
know you've only put me in as JJ Abrams
causing the oven once what we in Star
Wars movie then JJ Abrams I'm happy to
be in your Star Wars movie so you know
any character will do really truly it's
it is that would be great
did that would be an honor no truly it
would be great you see so much more as a
force on the dark side or a force for
good yeah I could go either way
I feel like I want to be the mystery one
that you don't know if she's good or bad
so it just keeps people guessing all the
time trouble and that is victory shiny
baby so good to see you again
you